[Music]
this is the first home to either of us
of everyone bringing the house wasn't
for us we wanted our own place the dogs
having their own yard is probably the
biggest thing for us we've kind of torn
everything down and built it back up the
way we wanted just being able to nail
stuff into the wall not get like the
sticky tabs like you can do whatever you
want with the home now Kansas City was
huge for us I think the people are what
we love the most about Kansas City gonna
have such a passion for the community
the food the football team they treat us
I mean just like we've been here our
whole entire life getting the house as
we plan on being here for 20 years plus
hey Google what does my calendar look
like tomorrow there are six entries for
tomorrow here are the first three at 7
a.m. you have OTAs I like to learn as
much as I can about tech especially when
it's trying to make life easier on me
and trying to give me the best
opportunities to maximize the time I
have to focus as much as I can on the
football field I try to push myself as
best I can especially during the
offseason you want to make sure your
body is in the perfect shape and so it's
kind of a thing where you're in full
brown butter I know and we're gone so
much so being able to check on the house
and make sure everything's in order is
always another advantage to that we can
turn the lights off we can do the music
we can watch the dogs around the house
it's good to see which one is the one
that I've always been so interested in
what they do while we're gone we had an
interior designer named Marcie and she
was awesome
and I was the yes-man so I just kind of
went and just said yes like it's fine no
matter what they take that is trusted my
intention so I basically got one thing
and it was like a baby with like tattoos
and that's that we have hanging up over
the family room everywhere else in the
house is completely Marci and Britney
and then I have my shoe room that I
literally wanted my whole entire lives
know that would that was big with me
[Music]
I've always loved shoes I've always
loved kind of changing the shoes with
what I'm wearing the Flint gets like the
final touch you can make your outfit and
so that's something that we have a
passion for and I'm glad we have a room
that we can kind of show that passion
and then plus whenever guys come over
onto eight let's go look at my shirt and
I say the first thing I'm gonna say
every single time I'm definitely on dude
[Music]